aïe ça fait mal et ça m'a l'air bien
content on n'achète pas content du tout
alors ah oui pourquoi pas ce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure car et 200000
côté chien coty chaque était abandonné
tous les ans en vacances
ah oui et c'est vrai tu crois je crois
oui il ya contiennent qu'un nom
abandonné eh bien je crois que cet été
il y en aura un seul toit oui tu vas
grandeur ni peut-être un lien ne nous
abandonnera écoute le chocolat coûte
cher oh non non non non non non gardez
moi regardez moi je t'aime
car des mois bon c'est d'accord je te
garantis mignien je te fais un bisou
de toute façon si je cite il n'y avait
qu'à regarder
j'aurais été chez tonton du luxe chez
tata darel relâcher mon cousin germain
raymond lefebvre oui en tout cas moi je
trouve ça dégueulasse qu'on abandonne
les petits chiens vous donnant des
normands il a alors dit oui alors sur
yon recommencerai plus non
parlez pas tous à la fois un mort comme
un simple bon d'accord alors écoutez si
vous regardez rôti chien chez vous à la
rentrée
je suis sûr qu'il vous auront gardé un
gros tas de crottin chocolat à leicester
tu aimes alain chamfort henri sanna et
bien voici alain chamfort
m